i'm in the hills outside oaxaca and my
guides omar and pepe are introducing me
to one of their favorite snacks okay
i can't say i share their enthusiasm
[Music]
it's very pasty it's very mealy it's
dude it says i bought it to you butter
no it tasted like sawdust gone warm
creamed up and pepper salad
wow they're really good
i'm not for me i feel kind of bad that
you didn't like them and i'm gonna give
it a second try if you're up for it
something also very very unique and
interesting let's go
that can't be difficult on the back of
that
liquid worm
if i'm gonna compete
on gabriella's manner even though
they're not my cup of tea
i've got to think of a way of using
those worms for sure it's going to be
sweeter sweeter unique also right what
we're looking for
we're looking for a honey ants honey
ants yes
here yeah
omar tells me that these ants come out
at night and collect nectar from the
plants and trees around them to produce
their own kind of honey that's the food
for the rest of the colony well how'd
you get the honey from
oh you just put it in your mouth and as
you put them out there you're gonna pop
cutting hill the cool thing is that the
ant doesn't die so you just like pop it
drink the honey and then you just put
the ant back into the hole ready yeah oh
there's some ants so that's a good sign
okay go for it just lay down on the
floor garden oh my god look how many we
found
that's all honey yeah but it looks like
a ball yeah it's their belly
really yes
and they're more hanging down here
all at the top oh my god they're all
there there's a hole full of sacks
how beautiful are they wow wow that's
plenty three four five they're all
different sizes too they're beautiful
and why aren't they biting because
they're what happens they're friendly
the actual sack is connected to the body
and they're like little balloons
aren't they they look like amber or not
so just bite the belly you just
literally suck on its sack
delicious yes
it tastes like sort of sweet
honey stroke cider vinegar from my main
course this one's my appetizer
oh i did just go for it
it's pretty unique isn't it yes
[Music]
and he's still alive
no it's sweet so how come it's so sweet
it's because of what they collect at
night all of the flowers and the nectar
from the different plants around them
and would you cook with them or just
i think it'll be really hard for you to
collect a lot of them yeah
the ants with delicious but i can't
transport them because
you suck that belly off the ant that's a
little treasure
a little nugget of magic that oaxaca has
as a secret ingredient that i can't take
[Music]
you